Mr Speaker it's like the ghost of prime
minister past is still here and I tell
the right honorable gentleman that he
should be careful about the stats to use
because the children's commissioner
warned the other prime minister about
peddling false narrative on child
poverty around those figures the truth
is rising bills and soaring mortgages
and plummeting real wages are pushing
more and more families to the brink
those already struggling are being hit
hardest by the Tory mortgage bombshell
and Rising food costs so can he tell us
how many primary school children have
been pushed into poverty since his
government took power
Deputy Prime Minister
I would say to right on wrong lady it is
this party not the party opposite which
extended free School meals to all five
six and seven-year-olds something the
party opposite failed to do and it sits
alongside many measures we are taking to
help people with the cost of living we
are paying half of families energy bills
last winter winter funded by our 75
windfall tax freezing fuel Duty helping
families with child care and delivering
on our pledge to reduce the debt it may
come as a surprise to the right
honorable lady but balancing the books
means more than working out how many
more Millions to take from her union pay
masters
Mr Speaker once again he talks about
balancing the books his party crashed
the economy
[Applause]
for working people in this country at
the moment new research out today shows
that 400 000 more primary school-aged
children are growing up in poverty since
his government came to office why does
he think that is the prime minister
I will take absolutely no lectures
whatsoever from the party opposite about
how we help children in the most need it
is record investment from this
government in education two billion
pounds more this year two billion pounds
next year which is giving those very
children the best possible start in life
ensuring that we have the highest
reading standards in the western world
and I have to say to thee I have to say
The Honorable lady
listen her leader says he hates Tree
Huggers they seem very keen on hugging
that magic money tree
foreign
Mr Speaker he doesn't even acknowledge
it let alone explain why child poverty
is rising what hope has he got of
solving it so let me try a simpler
question for him how many kids don't
have a permanent address today compared
to when labor left office in 2010.
Deputy Prime Minister
we could exchange all these numbers
across the dispatch
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
these are the numbers that matter there
are 1.7 million fewer people in absolute
poverty under this government 400
000 fewer children
200 000 for your pensioners and one
million fewer people of working age
because the single best route out of
poverty is a job and record numbers of
people for million more people under
this government have got a job that is
the difference between this party and
the party opposite who always leave
office with unemployment hire
Angela Rayner Mr Speaker what matters is
what people feel every single day at the
moment who are going to work and can't
afford their mortgage can't afford their
rent and can't afford their bills
because of this conservative government
there are 55 000 more children without a
permanent address today compared to when
they took office 13 years ago we've gone
from a labor cabinet focused on tackling
child poverty to Tory ministers who
won't even admit the problem just like
the question time in March 1996 they can
only offer excuses and not answers Lord
John Prescott said to Lord Michael
hesitine that day how can the right
honorable gentleman be so complacent in
the face of sheer misery created by by
his government's policies
27 years on why are we asking the exact
same thing
[Applause]
a little bit more if we carry on come on
Mr Speaker I know there's a reshuffle
coming up on the other side but this
audition the John Prescott's old job is
just getting a little bit hackneyed
it is this government that has lifted
000 children out of poverty the party
opposite I hear the ride my lady
claiming to be the party of working
people but under their policies people
can't even get to work they support just
stop oil protesters blocking our roads
their union pay masters stopping our
trains and of course they support their
hated Euless stopping cars across our
Capital while conservatives get Britain
moving labor are standing in everyone's
way
[Applause]